In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
Dear Jesus, may I enter into the eternal divine order of God to place my absolute
nothingness in the heart of the most holy Trinity, to give to my God the joy of fulfilling the
purpose of my existence by doing all the acts of my life through the immaculate heart of my
mother Mary and in the divine will of God. In this same manner may I live, pray, act, eat,
walk, sleep and do everything. May my soul be devoid of any other longings, wants or desires,
and may you my beloved divine will do with me whatever you want or desire.
All I ask is that you bind me to your most holy will so intimately that I may never swear from
carrying out what I know to be your good pleasure, and that I remain so docile to the movements of
your divine will, that you never perceive even a breath of resistance in my soul to your requests
of me. Come divine will with all the angels and saints, especially my sweet mother Mary,
to touch my forehead, to imprint on it the Holy Spirit, and infuse in me true light,
so that I may understand the truths and the good that are in these writings and prayers, amen.
We're almost at the end of volume 18 and we finish with a sound warning about the dangers
of the human will and just what you miss every time you give into the human will.
So I want to begin with February the 18th, 1926. Louisa said, "I felt oppressed because of many
thoughts that went through my mind and with the addition of the privation of my sweet Jesus. And
while I struggled between the hope that he would not leave me without him for too long,
my beloved Jesus took me by surprise and filled me all with himself in such a way that I could
no longer see myself but only Jesus, who formed around himself an immense sea of little flames."
Now here we have an image of the beatitudes of the divine will and this is extremely important,
they are around him in eternity. Now we are going to be told that it is our privilege to take as many
of them as we can while we are still in exile on the earth and they will come to full fruition
in heaven. So there's an urgency here for us to pick up as many as possible of these divine
abiatitudes which are the truths of the divine will. And so Louisa sees them as little flames
and these were all the truths that regarded his divinity and his lovable will. I would have wanted
to take all those little flames in order to know the one who is everything for me and to make him
known to all. Now notice the two-sided mystery there that first of all we come to know him as well as
possible and then we try and get other people to know him also. This is the reason why we set up
the classes and the school of spirituality but she said no first I couldn't find the human terms
in order to express what she was seeing. Secondly the littleness of my mind I couldn't handle these
concepts in order to be able to contain them nor she said the infinity it's not possible for me to
embrace it and the immensity I'm completely lost in it so she was looking at something in eternity
naturally enough if you reach out it's like a child reaching out for a sunbeam and when the child
closes his or her hand there's nothing in it even though they reached out for the sunbeam so she said
no no no I'm too small I'm too little how can I reach out to something that's utterly immense.
I could understand a little bit of everything she said that's one Corinthians two nine but
alas she said the celestial language is very different from the terrestrial this is something
we need to take on board because when the Lord speaks to us he is speaking his celestial language
to us this problem is illustrated very very very well in St. John's gospel where Jesus is
continuously speaking from the level of above where the divine language is and he's completely
being misunderstood by people who are reading from a terrestrial language and there is no connection
and Jesus has to in every conversation he has he has to lift up his the person he's speaking to or
the group he's speaking to to try and reach him on this divine level so there is a celestial language
and a terrestrial language therefore she said I couldn't find the words in which to make myself
understood in other words she couldn't translate it into our language more so since I'm with Jesus
I've the same language as him and we understand one another perfectly because she is lifted up
into the spiritual and therefore the language of the spiritual comes naturally to her but once
Jesus has withdrawn I find myself inside of myself and I feel such a change that I'm just barely able
to say a few things and only half mangled like babbling like a child and then she said while I
was swimming inside the sea of these little flames now notice she's there she's not looking at them
from a distance she's actually in this sea of flames which tells you how deeply into the divine
will she is beloved Jesus said it's true that the little newborn of my supreme volition can take part
in the beatitudes joys and happiness that the divine will has delivered her to the light all
these little flames that you see in the endless sea of my will are the symbol of the secret
beatitudes joys and happiness which the divine will contains and the more we enter into the divine
will the more we absorb it in ourselves the more we live it the more we will be able to enjoy these
beatitudes in heaven Jesus said I say secret because since I've not yet manifested the fullness of the
knowledge which the divine will contains nor are they the right dispositions in human beings in order
for me to manifest them he's speaking in 1926 and he's saying that humanity is not ready for this
nobody was ready for the manifestation of the divine will except louisa and the few people that
were around her and it spread very very slowly so he says the people were not ready all these
beatitudes had to remain at intra that's inside of the divinity okay and he wanted them to come
add extra that is outside of the divinity as we are waiting to put them out that's to bring them
add extra for the one who will be born live and carry out our life in the divine will with no
interruption now this is the person really living the divine will it's 24 7 3 6 5 there are no breaks
because he's going to show us in the next two messages how absolutely terrible it is to go back
into the human will we we just lose divine things so it has to be living in the divine will with no
interruption because her will being won with ours all the divine doors are opened look at that once
that unity of wills takes place all the divine doors are open heaven is open to us
and we can have what we want it's incredible we've heard Jesus say over and over that the person
in the divine will can take as much as they want and he's happy that they take as much as they want
so all the divine doors are opened and our most intimate secrets are revealed
now only to those who are deep into the divine will absolute commitment 24 7 so you see my daughter
each manifestation that i make to you about my will is a beatitude so each truth each man
event station is a beatitude released from the womb of the divinity and we can't have that
beatitude unless a we hear it b we receive it c we internalize it and d we live it
if we don't go through those stages the beatitude is there but it's not ours
each manifestation that i make of my will is a beatitude released from the womb of the divinity
which not only makes you happy and disposes you more to live in my will because each time
we go deeper into the divine will we're actually opened up to go deeper still and to understand more
and the more you understand the more you are opened to understand and it prepares you for
added knowledge so each step is vital and not only this but all heaven remains inundated
by that new beatitude which has come out of our womb that's very very interesting
in 1926 Jesus was saying that the saints who had got to heaven before that did not get to heaven
with this revelation because it hadn't been made and as each revelation of the divine will is made
and received by louisa and absorbed and lived and so on all the saints in heaven and all the angels
share in the beatitude so it actually increases their happiness because beatitude means happiness
oh how grateful they are that's the saints and the angels how grateful they are to you and how they
pray that i continue the manifestations in your will these beatitudes were closed into ourselves
by the human will and each act of the human will is a lock look at the word please if you have
your own book underlined it and put a big circle around it each act of the human will is a lock
to these celestial beatitudes this is how absolutely amazing this revelation is because you know in
all that we've heard up to now you you mightn't have taken on board really how serious it is
to go back into the human will but now you're being told you're locking yourself out of heaven
you're locking yourself out of the beatitudes of heaven and it's your own decision to do it
the saints that were in heaven before the revelation of the divine will they were never in that position
because they did the will of god insofar as they were able according to what was revealed in the
church at the time and so they have more and more and more and more to open up to and to experience
in heaven but we can have it on earth but we can lock ourselves out of the kingdom these beatitudes
were closed inside of ourselves by the human will each act of the human will is a lock to these
celestial beatitudes not only in time but in eternity that means if i say no to something now
it's no forever the opportunity was given to me now to open up i refused and therefore
that avenue is not open to me i find that a little bit terrifying i don't know about you
because each act of my will done on earth sows in the soul the seed of that beatitude
which she will enjoy in heaven so if you don't sow that seed on the earth there's nothing to
for the plant to grow in heaven without the seed it's useless to hope for the plant
therefore eternal consequences therefore you must go deeper and deeper into the divine will
so i think that that's last paragraph you need to put a VIP on it i just think it's absolutely
an incredible thing but i do on my book is i put a huge VIP on the page so that i won't miss it at
all so let's go into February the 21st 1926 and again we're still talking about the manifestations
of the divine will or the truths that are revealed i've told you that many times that you often get
two or three messages on the same theme i was feeling all immersed in the holy divine volition
the wheezer said a celestial and divine air surrounded me and an inaccessible light made itself
present to me well if you go to one timothy six sixteen paul will tell you that god lives
in inaccessible light same paul uses exactly the same expression as you find here so that
inaccessible light is god himself so a celestial and divine air surrounded me and an inaccessible
light made present to me as though in act all the acts of the supreme will which finding the same
will in me gave me their kiss and their love as we give the the acts of the divine will our kiss
and our love in rounds and i impressed my i love you on each act of the eternal volition
so here you've got a complete round there's the acts of god and there's louise's response
seemed to me that all of them wanted to be recognized by me these are all these acts
in order to have my requital perfect accord and mutual possession now in other words to enter
right into it and to possess and be possessed that's love now when i was in this state my sweet
jesus came out from within my interior which means of course that the kingdom of god is there
luke seventeen twenty one and with his divine hands he bound me within that light
now that eternal light is god in such a way that i could see nothing else but jesus that's what you
have in heaven you're surrounded by god you're in him so what you see and understand and experience
is him we call this the beatific vision so beatitude beatific is the same word it's the same reality
i could see nothing else but jesus his will and everything that it was doing how happy i felt
how many inexpressible joys i experienced because this is the beatitude of heaven
jesus himself was all in feast and felt such contentment and seeing me all for his will and
in his will that seemed he would forget about everything to occupy himself only with his will
forget about everything is forget about all that was going on on the earth and all the need for
chastisement and so on so that the divine will might be complete in me and try on thing in everything
it might obtain the purpose for which all things were created so in other words louisa is being
brought in to the fullness so as a result of this then the lord is going to continue to talk to her
about divine lives being developed from everything that we're doing then afterwards he said to me
my daughter little newborn of my will you must know that one who is born in my will can also be a
mother so here you've got this wonderful mixture of symbols that an infant can be a mother as well
by giving birth to many children of my supreme volition now as we go into volume 90 is going to
be explained to us why it is that we've got to be reborn all the time so in order to be mother
it's necessary to have sufficient matter in one's own interior in other words if a soul is to be
born out of our communion with the divine will there must be enough there to actually form it
for example if a woman is incapable of making the body on the little infant there won't be a body
she has to have that matter to be able to do that so he's using that image that spiritually
that it's got to be enough of this divine will communion in us to be able to give life to others
and this answers a question that you can get at an early stage from people coming to classes and
that is sort of that our prayers are kind of like magic if i say this prayer some kind of magic
effect is going to come out of it it's not it's the depth of communion that i have with god that
makes the difference and this is what we're being told here to be a mother of souls or a father of
souls that you have to have enough spiritual matter inside of you as so as to be able to form with
your own blood with one's own flesh and with continuous nourishment the birth that one wants
to give to the light if there's no seed and not enough matter it's useless to hope to become a mother
now since you have been born in my will he says to louisa in you there is the seed of fecundity
because louisa has long since reached inseparability with the lord and there is also the fully
sufficient matter of all the manifestations i have made to you in my will okay the question was
what is the matter and the answer is that you are filled you have enough of the truths of the divine
will inside of you operating inside of you that would give life to somebody else this is no magic
and prayers are not magic just because i say holy prayers and beautiful prayers doesn't mean
that something is happening it only happens if it's coming out of the depths of my being into the
depths of god so louisa has a enough seed and she has sufficient matter in all the manifestations
that the lord has made in his divine will it can be said that each knowledge or each truth i have
given to you can give birth to a child for my will these are called the divine lives your continuous
acts in my will our abundant nourishment in order to first form these children of heaven
within yourself and then deliver them as the triumph honor glory and crown of my will and as
the perennial joy of the motherhood deliver them perennial means forever and that's louisa it'll be
your happiness forever that you gave birth to so many divine lives so here the lord is telling us
that we can be very fruitful spiritually but only if these acts are continuous
now does that mean i'm putting a huge burden of prayer on you no i'm telling you that inside
of you there needs to be this communion with god that is real and every act including what i'm doing
now which is just literally just touching that object everything everything is part of this
communion everything every breath every glance every movement everything is part of it
that you can give life with absolutely everything but there needs to be enough of the divine will
truths inside of you that you know what you're doing it and you're doing it with the divine will
and in him you're doing it deliberately it's not just accidental see then with each additional
manifestation that means each truth that you learn it is one more birth that my will delivers
it is a divine life that goes forth for the good of other people it is to debilitate the
strengths of the human will in order to establish in it the fortress of the divine will so each
thing that we learn about the divine will uh lessons the power of the human will to dominate you and
that's why it's so extremely important for us to continuously read and study these writings because
you can slip off the ledge quite easily how attentive then you must be not to disperse anything you see
when we go away from this you you can disperse things without even realizing it even from the
smallest manifestations i make to you because you would deprive me of the honor of having one more
child that's the act in the divine will which can narrate to all one more good about my will in order
to give it to other people so that they might love it more they might let themselves be subdued
by the power of my supreme volition to put that in very very very simple language the divine will
is caught like the flu passes from one to the other if someone sees you you're different you're happy
your vibrant life is really meaningful and they're going through a very difficult time and it's
depressing and they're really what's happening in the world is really getting them down they will
come to you looking for a life that's our opportunity to open them up to life and so in the last paragraph
of volume 18 the Lord tells us we can peacefully navigate in the sea of the divine will we don't have
to get all head up about it and we don't have to get all worked up so luisa says then i don't know
i felt the usual fear that i might even just slightly go out of the divine will that's a continuous
fear that she has because she appreciates what she's doing very often we don't fully appreciate
what is involved we don't fully appreciate the seriousness of what we're into and so
Jesus came back to her all love and said to her my daughter why do you fear listen when you worry
now please please take this out with the book and write it up for yourself and put it somewhere
where you're going to see it every day when you worry and afflict yourself for fear that you might
go out of my will i laugh to myself and i make a joke because i know that the water of the sea of
my will that surrounds you is so great you wouldn't be able to find its boundaries in order to get out
now what he's saying to her is she is deeply in the divine will so she's in the position of a
little fish in the middle of the Atlantic ocean ask it to find a shore and it wouldn't know what
direction to go you wouldn't even know what a shore was if you asked you to find a particular
country it would have no idea it's completely lost in the water which is its life and that's the way
louisa is and if we're deep into divine will you don't have to worry the lord will just tip you
in order to get you back into position wherever you wanted to turn your step he said to the right
or to the left to the front or the back you'd be walking yes but always walking inside the sea
of my will and you yourself have formed this water with the many acts that you have done in it
now look at it that this sea that you find yourself in that you now can't get out of is actually
the sea formed by the multitudinous acts that you have done in the divine will and that it gets
deeper and deeper and wider and wider as time goes on you have formed the sea around yourself
from which you cannot go out so each act you do comes to form new water to expand even more the
sea of the supreme will inside and outside of you your very fears that you might go out of the origin
in which you have been born are waves that you form which in agitating you plunge you even more
deeply into the abyss of the sea of my will so what jesus is saying here is that this fear that we
can have of going out of the divine will is the very thing that makes you plunge even more deeply
into it and therefore it keeps you safe so this is why i don't approach you he said because i know
where you are and i know how you are he knows everything about us rather i call your attention
to live in peace in my will or i give you a surprise by telling you more surprising things
on my eternal volition in such a way that surprise you forget about everything including your fears
and with peace you navigate the sea of my will and i who am the divine hellsman and the boat
delight in guiding the one who lives in my supreme will and is all for it so
luisa then finishes by saying everything be for the glory of god okay so now we begin volume 19
and we're starting the second half it's like as if we're starting all over against taking us 10
years well not quite because that people i started with 10 years ago up in volume 34 or something
what's taken us many years to get to this point and you might say to yourself it'll take as many
to get to the rest of it it won't because you have all that material behind you to understand
where we're going but very significantly for me volume 19 begins with the need to be continuously
reborn in the divine will now i love this because i don't know about you i could manage to be faithful
for one nanosecond i didn't say a minute there's a lot of seconds in a minute and a lot of nanoseconds
in a second okay and so if you've got to be continuously reborn in the divine will that's okay
so here we're going to realize why it is that Jesus has been calling luisa the new born in his
divine will he's going to explain the importance of being in that position of coming fresh into the
divine will and you will be able to see therefore the answer to a question that you'll get probably
in volume one from your students that the pravenian act is certainly not enough it's not a done deal
because some people have taught over the years that surely i've done my pravenian act doesn't
that set up the day and the answer is no it doesn't if the first breath you took in the morning was
to do you for 24 hours you'd be in real trouble if the first class of water you took at the beginning
of the day was to do you for the whole day you wouldn't be doing well if the first bit of food you
talk at the beginning of the day was to do you for 24 hours you'd be pretty slim so we've got to be
continuously reborn into the divine will so this is February the 23rd 1926 and luisa begins by saying
my love and my life Jesus come to the help of my weakness and of my reluctance in writing she has
never stopped being reluctant in writing i'm glad he pushed her even more let your own will come to
write that i may put nothing of my own but only all that you want me to write and you my mother and
celestial mother of the divine will come to guide my hand while i write lend me the words facilitate
me in the concepts which Jesus places in my mind that i may wordily write about your most holy will
so as to make my sweet Jesus content now luisa's talking about writing but for all of you who are
teaching classes this is a very good prayer that you ask blessed mother to guide you and to guide
your thoughts and your words and to facilitate the concepts you need to explain things and so on
so that you can be much more fruitful as a life giver for others so luisa said i was thinking to
myself why does pleasure Jesus so often call me the little newborn of his most holy will maybe i'm
still so bad you see she she comes to these very quick decisions which many of us do and then the
Lord has to open up the profound reason as to why he calls her this so while i was thinking about
this my adorable Jesus classed his arms around my neck and embracing me tightly to his heart he
said to the little newborn of my will i want to deny nothing that's a very important statement those
of you who have read and studied the life and work of padre pio will know that when he was asked
why have you been able to work so many miracles for the Lord and his answer was i deny him nothing
so he denies me nothing now many of the saints have said that i deny him nothing he denies me nothing
so what you're looking at is a very complete love in which the love is given generously and
completely on both sides so Jesus said to i don't deny you anything do you want to know then why i
call you the little newborn newborn means to be in the act of being born all the time and you must be
reborn in each one of your acts in the divine will so i want to give you the first letter of peter
chapter two verses two to five and nine to twelve where he talks about us being newborn in the kingdom
of god not only this but in order to be repaid for all the oppositions of the human wills my will
wants to call you into my volition to make you be reborn so many times for as many times as the
human wills have opposed it ah so here you're making reparation for all the opposition to the
divine will by being reborn every nanosecond no nanoseconds are not something louise and you about
but i'm talking about science as it is now so here you're making reparation therefore it's
necessary to keep you always and you born when one is in the act of being born it is easy to
make her be reborn as many times as one wants and to preserve her without the growth of the human
will that's what he's after is to keep the human will out of it so you're being reborn to the divine
will at every moment and therefore everything in you is grace is privilege is gift and he said
when the soul grows it's actually more difficult to keep her without the life of her own self i'm
going to translate that into english for you when we grow up we get too big for our boots
and when we think we have made progress spiritually we think that we can you know
dictate to other people and we can have fallen off the the ledge completely ourselves so he keeps her
in this continuous act of being born now he's going to turn around and say the same thing
in the next paragraph using different language and the different language you will understand because
he's going to say that to truly be in the divine will you've got to die to the human will at every
nanosecond so that the divine will can be reborn in you every nanosecond now we're into language
we understand okay so this is not all he said it was necessary be fitting and right for the new
born of my will and for our will itself that she would unite herself to that single act and this is
what he wants of us that we will unite that single act which is one act but all the other acts are
contained in this one act okay it's the singularity that is the divine will at one act no succession of
acts everything is in it okay and so he joins us to that hence you are in this position of coming
into this being all the time and just as the single act gives the divinity the divine being
all the greatness the magnificence the immensity the eternity the power in some it encloses everything
to make whatever it wants come out of this one divine act in the same way our little new born
of our will uniting with the single act of the eternal will was to do always one single act that
is to remain always in the continuous act of being born this one thing the sun does one thing it gives
light doesn't do anything else the light has all kinds of properties as we know and has a numerous
effects but it's only the one thing that it's doing and so the Lord says in keeping you in the divine
will enclosed it is to make whatever it wants come out of this one act so it must be a continuous
act of being born only doing one thing the divine will and while doing one single act she would be
reborn continuously but reborn to what she would be reborn to new beauty new sanctity new light
and that new likeness of our creator now likeness of our creator is Romans 8 28 and Genesis 1 27
so this means that if we are held in this position of being reborn at every nanosecond
then it means that we remain fresh we remain energized we remain full of life we're never fated
we're never jaded we're never fed up we're never depressed we're in the act of being born of coming
into being at every single second it's a very wonderful concept and so you're being reborn to
new beauty of course we're talking about interior beauty now for those of us who are getting old
and hegored to new sanctity to new light to new likeness of our creator and as you are reborn
in our will the divinity feels repaid for the purpose for which it issued the whole creation
because of this one person responding the Lord says it was all worth it i find it fascinating
and so i don't think we can imagine how much the Lord wants each one of us to get as deeply as
possible into the divine will i don't think we can imagine it and i don't think we can imagine
the joy he feels when we take another step and another step a very simple image of it would be
the great joy that a parent experiences when a child scores greater points or achieves something
they thought they couldn't achieve and moves on and is more successful and is getting there in life
that wonderful sense that the parent has so we're talking about this great joy that we can give
to god therefore by just allowing ourselves to be reborn at every second so clasping you to the
divine bosom the divine will fills you with joy and with infinite graces infinite notice the word
and the divine will manifest to you more knowledge about our will and in giving you no time that is
no time for self to assert itself no time for stubbornness no time for rebellion it makes you
be reborn again and again in the divine will so here you've got this tension of death and resurrection
is the other expression that you can use that the human will is dying and the divine will is being
reborn at every second so because it's happening continuously the soul is in this tension of death
and resurrection and that's what Jesus says in the next very short paragraph moreover these continuous
births make you die continuously to your will to your weaknesses to miseries and to all that does
not belong to our will how beautiful is the destiny of the newborn it's lovely so continuous death
to the divine will so you've heard me say for years that it's actually important as far as i'm concerned
anyway to say out loud if necessary when things are going against you not my will but die and be done
not my will but die and be done not my will but die and be done i'll get used to this death and
resurrection if you ever get used to it but at least get into the habit of adjusting yourself
to the divine will so beside that i want to give you Galatians 614 and so in the final paragraph
of this section Jesus needs to be reborn continuously in each one of us now as we die to the divine will
he can be reborn in us see i too was born one time but that birth makes me be born continuously i am
reborn in each consecrated host i am reborn every time the creature returns to me in grace the first
birth gave me the field to make me be reborn always this is how the divine works after they are done
once their continuous act remains without ever ending the only do it once and then it continues
forever so that's your one single act the same will be with my little newborn of my will after she is
born once the act of her continuous birth will remain this is why i am so careful not to let your
will enter into you do you remember in the early volumes when louisa was struggling with various
things jesus would say to her don't put your will into it don't put your will into it you know your
feelings are doing this she she said a number of times i wanted to feel resentful and he said
don't put your will into it helping her to do this death and resurrection thing now he isn't as
dramatically involved with you and me well maybe with you but no it may so you have to remind yourself
to let this death and resurrection happen so this is why i am careful not to let your will enter into
you and i surround you with so much grace so that you may always be reborn in my will and my will
be reborn in you so we're going to continue with this message and we're going to be told very simply
which needs to be told if we're just ordinary folks like me don't lose time over tribals
this dying and rising has got to be completely continuous if the divine will is to thrive inside
of us so there must be no self preoccupation about anything so louisa said i continued
amid my usual fears the fears are temptation to self-occupation and beloved jesus making himself
seen all goodness told make my daughter do not lose time because every time you occupy yourself
with yourself it is an act of divine will that you lose so what you're losing is something infinite
and if you knew what it means to lose a single act of my will and it stops because we have no
ability to understand what he's saying he said you lose a divine act an act which embraces everything
and everyone and which contains all the goods that exist in heaven and on earth that's what you're
losing for some kind of trifle it makes our little tiny struggles about ourselves look completely
stupid more so since my will is a continuous act which never stops its course nor can it wait
for you now that's important and i mean as parents you will have said often and often to children
we're not waiting for you we're getting into the car and we're going so if you're still in the house
you're still there and the child very often needs that kind of stimulus to get it moving
and that's what jesus says here the divine acts continue
if i don't get on board the train the train goes on if i don't board the airplane the flight goes out
i lose so the divine will will not wait for you when you stop with your fears it is more appropriate
for you to follow the divine will in its continuous course than for the divine will have to wait for
you to place yourself on the way in order to follow it now this is probably something quite
frequent with us the divine will has to wait until we come around and get erect together
and then put ourselves back into the divine will and start all over again but we're losing an
awful lot of time and we're losing treasures that are beyond our ability to grasp and we've got to
wake up to this i think we need to ask the lord to open our eyes and to open our minds to understand
the seriousness of what we're actually doing and not only he said would you lose time but having
to pacify you number one and to raise you up from your fears number two in order to put you on the
way in my will you force me to occupy myself with things that do not regard the divine volition
whoops we get him to occupy himself with our stupidities instead of us dealing with the eternal
realities that he wants us to deal with you're very angel he said who is near you remains on
an empty stomach because every act you do in the divine will as you follow its course is one more
accidental beatitude which he enjoys your angel is involved your angel has a stake in this and
your angel really wants you to move on because when we hold back we're holding back something
that that angel will have in eternity because they were guarding us i think that really needs
to be looked at the position of the guardian angel because we kind of take them for granted
you're very angel who is near you remains on an empty stomach because every act you do in the
divine will as you follow its course is one more accidental beatitude which he enjoys being near
you and it is doubled paradise of joys that you offer him in such a way that he feels happy in his
destiny of having you in his custody so if we're moving on in the divine will the angel is happy
if we're holding back then it's not so wonderful and since the joys of heaven are communal your
angel offers the accidental beatitude he has received from you he's doubled paradise to the
whole celestial court nobody in heaven wants everything for themselves and he offers it as
the fruit of the divine will of his protected one all make feast and magnify and praise the power
the sanctity and the immensity of my will and therefore he said be attentive in my will one cannot
lose time now this has been emphasized a number of times tonight where you must not lose time
we must move on in my will one cannot lose time there is much to do you have to follow the act of
God which is never interrupted now your text probably says the act of God which is not English
it's transliteration from Italian having said this Jesus disappeared and I remained concerned in
seeing the evil that I was doing that is in occupying herself with herself and I said to myself how
can it ever be possible that by placing myself in the divine will forgetting about everything else
as if nothing else existed for me but the eternal will alone I take part in all that this lovable
will contains and Jesus returning said my daughter it is just for one who is born in my will to
know the secrets that the divine will contains and besides the thing in itself is very easy
and is though natural and then he begins to explain it suppose that you want to go and live in a house
either for a short time or forever in which there's beautiful music and a fragrant air through which
one feels infused with new life indeed you had not put that music or that balsamic air in it but
since you find yourself in that house which is not yours you come to enjoy both the music and the
fragrant air which regenerates your strength and your life it adds new life to you so add that this
house contains enchanting paintings beautiful things that unwraptured gardens which you've never seen
before with so many different plants and flowers that it's impossible to account them all delicious
lunches that you've never enjoyed before or how you amuse yourself how you delight and enjoy yourself
in admiring so many beauties in savoring food so tasty however of all this nothing was made or
placed by you in the house anyway yet you take part in everything just by being in that house
so there is that wonderful donation i think if any of us have to go and explain it we would try
some kind of highfalutin language and make a nonsense out of it whereas jesus uses the simplest
possible illustration that by being in the house you can enjoy what's in the house so he's saying
that by being in the divine will you enjoy everything that is there god opens himself up
completely to us his generosity is beyond imagining so now he's going to go on and explain
this thing that he has taught that he has illustrated and now he's going to explain it so here's the
example for all teachers you know you teach the thing you illustrated you explain it and so
he's going to tell us in the explanation of the next paragraph that what happens in the natural
order also happens in the supernatural order in other words god teaches us about the supernatural
order by the things that are around us now if this happens in the natural order much more easily
can it happen in the supernatural order of my will by entering into it the soul forms one single
act with the divine will and as though naturally she takes part in all that the divine will does
and all that it contains more so since in order to live in the divine will the soul is first stripped
of the garments of the old guilty adam now notice this is very very clear nothing unholy or unworthy
can enter the presence of god and so if any of the students in our classes think that you can be in
the divine will without going through purification no no that can't happen in fact one of the signs
that you are being serious about your relationship with god is that he brings you through a continuous
purification and he is so thorough on the purification that he brings to each one of us in our ordinary
everyday lives and the purification can be internal and nothing to do with your external circumstances
or it can be your external circumstances as well he includes illness and everything that
happens to you for this internal purification if that's not happening i doubt if the union is there
because nothing unholy or unworthy can enter the presence of god if i'm a selfish old me
forget about it i'm not in the divine will it's that simple so it's terribly important that the soul
is first stripped of the garments of the old guilty adam and is clothed and you dirt your death and
resurrection clothed and you with the garments of the new and the holy adam god is holy the viticus
twenty one two i think is says you shall be holy for i am holy says the lord the prophet
amr said only two who are alike can walk together so if we're to live in union with god one with god
we have to be alike therefore the unholyness in me has got to go the selfishness in me is got to go
the worldliness in me is got to go and so it's put very well in one sentence here
that you've got to be stripped of the garments of the old guilty adam and clothed it in you
in the garments of the new and the holy adam the garment you get in the divine will is made of light
now god is light so we're literally clothed in god therefore all the smudges of all kinds of
sins have got to go you can't mix the two her garment is the light of the supreme will itself
so i want to give you sam one hundred and four verse two there that in the transfiguration Jesus
was clothed in a garment of light in the resurrection Jesus was clothed in a garment of light and long
before then the samus says that god is clothed in a garment of light so you now know Jesus in the
transfiguration was manifesting his divinity and of course he proved his divinity in the
resurrection her garment is the light of the supreme will itself through which all his divine
manners his ways are communicated to her because as amos said only to who are alike can walk together
so we have to learn the divine ways now i could give you endless references on that
they're all over the sams you can find them lord teach me your ways
and his ways are communicated to us now you remember that in Isaiah 55 verses 4 to 8 i think it is
that god said my ways are not your ways my ways are as different to your ways as the heavens are
from the earth so we have to learn his heavenly ways and let go the earthly ways so that we can
walk with him and so his ways are noble and communicative to all this light makes her lose
the human features and restores to her the likeness of her creator there's your Romans 8 29 again
and Genesis 27 what is the wonder then if you take part in all that the divine will possess us
since there's only one life and there's only one will therefore be attentive i recommend to you
be always faithful to me and your Jesus will keep the pace of making you live always in his will
i will be on guard that you will never go out of it so we have to let this continuous death and
resurrection happen to us i think that's a very important lesson to learn at the beginning of a new
year. So thank you for joining me and God bless!